Using isinstance we could define the Bear chase like this. We'll first check if
the victims up a tree if not he is definitely eatable. If he is up a tree well
it depends whether a Black Bear or a Grizzly Bear. If we're a Black Bear we
climb the tree, if we're a Grizzly Gear we knock down the tree. Either of those
makes the victim eatable. If not, the victim is not eatable. We don't have a
way, to get to the victim if we're some, weak kind of Bear that can't do either
of those two things. Then, if the victim's eatable, we eat the victim, but
otherwise there's no dinner for the Bear. Very sad,[SOUND] no dinner, no dinner.
So think about how you like that code. I'm going to show you another possible
way to deal with this.